صباح الخير عليكم ااا انا معايا المراه
الحديديه اماني حلمي خليل وهي دلوقتي على
فكره بقت 56 سنه ولسه بتشارك لسه بتشارك
في بطولات يا اماني
عندي اللي جايه ان شاء الله في طوكيو
والميرفان ودي هتبقى رقم السادسه بالنسبه
تانيه وهو بصراحه قبل المجال البنوك كانت
اهلي دخلوني الرياضه على اساس ان انا كنا
بنسافر كثير فعشان اتاكم على البلد واتعلم
اللغه الرياضه هي اللي كانت بتشجعني ان
انا همم اعرف ناس واتعلم اللغه فحبوني في
الرياضه من ساعتها ما بطلتش انت انا
ملاحظه كمان انت بتجري يعني هي كانت بتجري
دلوقت في الشارع مش في النادي مثلا اهو
[موسيقى]
المسافات اللي انا باجريها مسافات طويله
اا الحمد لله في امان وهمم وباحب باشوف في
المنظر الناتشورال اكثر منها لما بكون
متقيده جوه النادي بس ساعات كده ساعات كده
طب كلميني على المراه الحديديه بقى اللقب
ده والتحدي اللي دخلتيه همم يعني كانت ايه
ابرز ملامحه وهمم والصعوبات اللي واجهتيها
والله انا طول عمري باجري بصراحه لكن لقب
المراه الحديديه جاءت لما عملت سباق
الاعير يعني هو ده سباق صعب شويتين لان
المسافات بتاعته طويله اربعه كيلو عوم في
البحر المفتوح وبعدين نخش على 180 كيلو
عجل وبعدين نخلص فيلم 42 فكان وقتها مش
سهل انك تلاقي سيدات وبالذات في سني كنت
لسه تميت 50 ان انا اخلص سباق زي ده فلما
خلصته واتمرنت له طبعا واتحقق ايه بقت
اللقب جامد كده ولقت ولقيت فيها وكل الناس
دلوقت بقت بتشوف انا عملت ايه وهمم
وشجعهم ان هم يعملوا كده عادي 13 ساعه
متواصله مضبوط 13 سباق خد مني 13 ساعه و11
دقيقه عقبال ما خلصته
من اهلك سبورتنج لك عيلتك اولادك همم
كلميني كده على الموضوع ده طبعا انا في
وسط رجاله جوزي استاذ بالجامعه واولادي
الاثنين كان وقتها حتى في الجامعه وقتها
همم فعلا
من غيرهم انا ما كنتش هاقدر احقق اللي انا
احقق ده برده يعني الحمد لله ان هم كان
رجاله وقفوا معي واحده ست ان شافه ان انا
باجري في الشارع والساعه 5:00 الصبح بدري
منزل الصبح بدري يعني صعب قوي ان جوزي
يبقى موافق على حاجه زي كده بس شايف ان
انا محتاجه التمرين ده فوافق وبعدين كنت
باخذ وقت كثير قوي من اليوم سبع ساعات
تدريب في اليوم عشان احقق السباق الرجل
الحديدي
في السباق شاركوكي في اخر مرحله اه دي
كانت مفاجاه بالي لان ما كنتش متوقع نعمله
كده في اخر السباق تعبت شويه في وقت الجري
لانك كنت خلصت العجل وخلصت 30 كيلو جري
وضحكت جسمانيا اول مره تحس ان جسمي قفش
وقف ولادي كان وقتها معايا وكانوا قعدوا
يشجعوا لي بانهم يغنوا معايا عشان انسى
الوجع اللي في جسمي لغايه لما دخلوني
الفيش لاين فكانت حاجه جميله انهم وجوزي
طبعا كان فرحان جدا وحتى جوزي اللي ما
بيجريش خالص اجري معي اخر 200 متر يس ههه
كانت حلوه بس عمري ما اقدر انسى السباق ده
لان اثر في حياتي جدا جدا يعني قله التحدي
اللي جاي اللي انت شايفاه او الصعوبات
اللي انت مثلا شايفه انك بتواجهها في
المجايده
الاول كان في صعوبات جامده جدا ان انا
انزل اجري في الشارع ده ما كانش سهل
دلوقت بقت الناس بتشجعني وبتشوفني عشان
شافه
بالاقي صعوبه جدا ان انا اقدر انزل
بالعجله من غير ما احد ما يضايقني
العربيات ما تدليش ال- الطريق ان انا اعدي
او امشي بيه فباضطر لازم اطلع على السحره
بره عشان اتمرن عكس لما باشوفه في الاجانب
بره ممكن تطلعي مره بيتك وتبتدي فدي
لصعوبات يعني اللي بلاقيها بس الحمد لله
بقيت اسهل شكرا لك جدا يا اماني وبالتوفيق
ان شاء الله شكرا لكم شكرا يا سهام شكرا
نادين وشكرا يا سمر وشكرا لضيفتك الكريم
بهذه الفقره ودائما رافعين راسنا النساء
الحديديات والنساء القويات في هذه الدنيا
شكرا جزيلا لكم من القاهره سمر بشوات صباح
العربيه وضيفتها اماني